projetons-nous dans un monde où Bayon
Nant et Renn sont 20 m sous l'eau un
monde où le Danemark n'est plus qu'une
île isolée un monde avec une mer entre
l'Algérie et la Tunisie et une autre mer
encore plus grande au nord du Brésil et
ça ce ne sont que quelques exemples de
ce qui pourrait arriver si toute la
glace de la planète Terre fondait salut
c'est Lucas cette semaine j'ai voulu
faire un peu de science-fiction et
imaginer le monde si toute la glace
avait fondu ça c'est colossal et ça
changerait totalement la géographie du
monde certaines villes et territoires
entiers serait recouvert d'eau on va
explorer tout ça ensemble on
découvrirait aussi des zones immenses
invisibles aujourd'hui pour ce nouvel
épisode de la grande explication je me
suis demander quelles pourrai être les
conséquences concrètes d'une disparition
complète des glaces et par rapport à ce
scénario bien sûr extrême qu'est-ce
qu'on risquerait je vous
explique juste avant de se plonger en
détail sur les cartes de ce monde
transformé prenons deux glaçons je les
mets dans ce premier bol et vous voyez
l'eau arrive à peu près jusqu'à ce trait
je prends deux autres glaçons à peu près
de la même taille que je mets met cette
fois au-dessus de ce bol là et vous
voyez l'eau arrive à peu près au même
niveau ces de ver je les garde là ils
nous rerviront un peu plus tard en
attendant un monde où toute la glace à
fondu ça ressemble à
ça voici d'abord la Bretagne dans ce
monde là elle est profondément
transformé on aurait une sorte d'île
avec la Bretagne l'intérieur de la
Bretagne qui est une altitude un petit
peu plus haute qui resterait mais
finalement tout ça serait entouré d'eau
en fait si absolument toute la glace de
la planète fondait le niveau des océans
augmenterait de 66 m environ ça c'est la
hausse estimée dans deux rapports
récents du GC et 66 m à titre de
comparaison c'est environ 10 m de plus
que ce qui sépare le sol du premier
étage de la Tour Effel ou l'équivalent
d'un immeuble de 23 étages résultat la
côte ouest de la France se retrouve en
grande partie sous l'eau La Rochelle
sous l'eau Bordeaux totalement sous
l'eau également c'est aussi le cas de la
côte méditerranéenne l'eau remonte
notamment le long de la vallée du rô
presque jusqu'à
Montelimar les côtes du nord de la
France sont aussi largement touchées ici
aussi la mer remonte le long des fleuves
et va jusqu'à entrer dans hien et dans
Paris mais cette fondte totale des
glaces transforme aussi bien sûr plein
d'autres endroits dans le
monde sur plusieurs continents des
merses géantes apparaissent comme ici en
plein milieu de l'Australie c'est aussi
le cas de l'autre côté du monde au
Brésil le long du fleuve Amazone et
ailleurs voici d'autres exemples de ce
que ça pourrait donner si on regarde les
États-Unis ça serait l'est des
États-Unis qui serait aussi sous l'eau
donc New York par exemple ou ensuite si
on regarde l'Afrique donc là c'est
plutôt l'ouest de l'Afrique qui serait
impacté après c'est Londres qui serait
complètement les pieds dans l'eau ça
serait les Pays-Bas qui disparaîtrait en
fait ça sera un ensemble de capital qui
finalement serait sous l'eau puisqueen
fait on a tendance aujourd'hui à
s'installer vraiment au bord de l'eau et
c'était stratégique au cours du
développement de nos sociétés juste
avant de continuer on va apporter une
petite précision bien sûr ces cartes
sont des versions simplifiées pour les
dessiner on s'est basé sur des sites qui
donnent l'altitude des côtes à
différents endroits dans et on a ensuite
simplifié les tracés pour les rendre
plus lisibles merci d'ailleurs aux
graphistes de brut qui ont réalisé ce
travail dans la réalité par exemple
l'eau ne monterait pas forcément partout
à la même hauteur le rythme de la montée
des EAU le type de sol ou certaines
barrières naturelles pourrai aussi
modifier cette répartition ces cartes
elles permettent quand même d'avoir une
idée du potentiel de la fonte totale des
glaces si on regarde l'Asie du Sud-Est
alors là par contre c'est vraiment la
catastrophe ça veut dire Tokyo Beijing
ça veut dire Bangkok sous l'eau ça veut
dire Jakarta il y a des pays entiers qui
disparent arrêit en parallèle de ces
zones englouties on découvre aussi
d'immens terres invisibles
aujourd'hui ces montagnes jusqu'ici
elles étaient cachées par plusieurs
mètres de glace bienvenue au Groenland
plus globalement voici le relief sous la
glace tel que reconstitué par une étude
américaine sur l'océan tout autour on
trouve aujourd'hui d'immenses espaces de
banquises ça veut dire que cette couche
de glace en fait elle disparaîtrait
aussi donc ça veut dire qu'on aurait un
océan l'océan Arctique qui sera un océan
noir qui du coup n'aurait plus du tout
l'écosystème on peut imaginer avec des
ours des foces de l'autre côté du globe
voici à quoi ressemble le continent
antarctique sous la glace mais alors que
se passerait-il si l'eau montait de 66 m
là d'un coup on a des îles absolument
partout il y a une grosse partie en fait
de l'Antarctique qui est située sous le
niveau marin et c'est des îles c'est des
canyons il y a une chaîne de montagnes
aussi qui traversent Antarctique j'ai
découvert que dans un deuxième temps les
terres de l'Antarctique comme cell du
Groenland remontent probablement car
aujourd'hui le niveau est en fait
abaissé par le poids de la glace si on
enlève ce poids en fait il va remonter
petit à petit mais ça va prendre des des
milliers d'années toujours selon l'étude
américaine à terme ça donne ça si on
retire le poids de la glace dans les
deux continents une plus grande partie
ressort de l'eau avant de voir si ce
scénario catastrophe de 6 cm en plus est
vraiment possible déjà essayons de voir
d'où pourrait venir toutes cette
[Musique]
eau sur terre aujourd'hui environ 10 %
des surfaces TER TER restre et 6 % des
océans sont couverts de glace peut
vraiment séparer de grands groupes donc
tout ce qui est glace continentale donc
qui se forme sur les continents à partir
des précipitations de de neige ce qu'on
appelle la glace continentale c'est par
exemple la calote glaciaire qui recouvre
le Groenland et celle qui recouvre
l'Antarctique mais aussi les glaciers de
montagne comme la mer de glace dans le
massif du Mont-Blanc et après il y a un
dernier réservoir aussi c'est ce qu'on
appelle le PERG sol donc en Sibérie au
nord du Canada et cette eau en fait elle
va être gelée dans le sol mais toute
l'année et ensuite toute la glace de mer
qui elle est formée directement dans les
océans par diminution en fait de la
température se forme à partir d'une
température de Mo- 2°gr c'est en dessous
de zéro parce que c'est de l'eau qui est
salé et ça va de 1 m jusqu'à 5 m si on a
des plaques de banquis qui montent les
unes sur les autres par exemple s
l'augmentation de la la température
l'ensemble de de ces réservoirs en fait
est impacté en fait vous allez voir que
quand on s'intéresse à la montée des
océans toutes ces réserves sont loin
d'avoir le même poids reprenons donc
notre petite expérience que vous
connaissez peut-être et bien dans le
verre numéro 2 où les glaçons étaient
au-dessus on voit que le niveau de l'eau
a pas mal augmenté on a environ 1 cm en
plus et si on prend le verre numéro 1 où
les glaçons était à l'intérieur et bien
l'eau n'a pas du tout augmenté et bien
sur terre c'est un peu pareil la glace
de mer donc la banquise qui est déjà
dans l'eau quand elle fond elle ne fait
pas monter le niveau des océans c'est
exactement comme ce verre la hausse elle
est du à la fondte des réserves de glace
qui sont en dehors de l'eau et justement
j'ai trouvé un rapport du GC qui estime
le potentiel pour chacune de ces
réserves d'abord la fonte du pergadisol
ou permafrost en anglais pourrait
entraîner une hausse des océans de
seulement 2 à 10 cm environ la fonte de
tous les glaciers une hausse d'environ
41 cm ce serait déjà beaucoup plus pour
la fonte de toute la calote glaciaire du
Groenland environ 7,4 m et pour la fonte
de la calotte glaciaire Antarctique ça
ferait 58,3 m la grande contribution la
ha du niveau marin viendrait de
l'Antarctique donc si on retire toute la
glace qu'il y a sur ce continent cette
glace elle fait en moyenne 2,5 km
d'épaisseur à certains endroits elle
peut même atteindre 4 km donc c'est
vraiment gigantesque c'est comme un un
gâteau de glace finalement si on
additionne tout ça on retombe bien sur
les 6 cm environ qu'on a essayé de
représenter tout à l'heure sur les
cartes alors je me suis demandé cette
fondte totale et cette montée extrême
des EAU est-ce qu'il y a des chances
qu'on les connaisse et si oui à quelle
condition
si on regarde entre 1900 et 2020 le
niveau des océans a augmenté d'une
vingtaine de centimètres selon la
dernière synthèse du GC publié en 2023
j'ai demandé à la glaciologue lid
lesescarontier s'il semblait possible
qu'un jour on connaisse cette hausse de
6 cm c'est pas réaliste et heureusement
heureusement pour nous d'ailleurs pour
atteindre en totalité il faudrait une
augmentation de la température de
l'ordre de 6 7°gr et ça heureusement ça
n'arrivera pas parce que je pense qu'on
serait plus là pour pour en parler ou
pour le mesurer mais alors de combien
l'eau peut-elle monter à court terme en
fait le JC note plusieurs possibilités
déjà dans un scénario à fort impact le
niveau de l'eau pourrait approcher les 2
m en 2100 et dépasser les 15 m d'ici
2300 le Jeck indique cependant que la
probabilité de cette option est faible
d'autres scénarios atteignent environ 1
m d'ici 2100 et 2 à 7 m d'ici 2300 à 1 m
ou à 2 m les impacts seraient bien sûr
moins importants que ce qu'on a montré
tout à l'heure si toute la glace fondait
mais vous le voyez plusieurs côtes
seraient quand même affecté 1 2 m de ha
du niveau marin ça veut dire Bordeaux
sous l'eau ça veut dire La Rochelle sous
l'eau arle Le Havre juste un mtre en
fait ça ça a vraiment des impacts très
très forts parce qu'en fait c'est un M
en moyenne mais il y a des endroits ce
sera plus il a des endroits aussi ce
sera moins ça peut se transformer en 5
10 m lors d'un événement extrême il a
une tempête et et d'un coup voilà il y a
des il y a des inondations absolument
partout ces scénarios là c'est si on
continue à rejeter de grandes quantités
de gaz à effet de ser à l'inverse
toujours selon le GC si on réduit
rapidement ce type de rejet la hausse
pourrait être contenue autour de 50 cm
en 2100 et entre 50 cm et 3 m en 2300
c'est déjà un problème qui touche un
certain nombre de pays comme par exemple
les petites îles du du Pacifique on a
entendu parler il y a pas très longtemps
des Samoas qui cherchaient en fait à se
réinstaller à d'autres endroits et c'est
l'Australie qui va les accueillir là
déjà on s attend ce qui est 10 % de la
population mondiale d'ici la fin du
siècle qui soit impacté en fait par la
hausse du niveau marin donc des gens à
relocaliser et donc qui va les
accueillir comment ça va se passer
comment l'anticiper pour éviter les les
conflits la fonte des glaces elle peut
aussi entraîner d'autres conséquences
bien moins visibles sur les cartes pour
ne citer que quelques exemples la
destruction d'habitat d'animaux la
perturbation de courants marin ou encore
la réduction des réserves d'eau potable
du à la disparition des glaciers ou à
des remontées d'eau aller dans les
nappes fratiques pour résumer la montée
des EAU elle devrait continuer sur des
centaines d'années et ça c'est dû à
l'inertie de la fonte des glaces mais
selon de nombreux scientifiques il est
encore possible de réduire le rythme et
le niveau total de cette hausse on a
vraiment la la solution aujourd'hui la
solution au problème qui est qui est
saine d'arrêter d'utiliser des énergies
fossiles et de limiter notre
consommation et de passer au au
renouvelable
[Musique]
quoi
j'espère que cet épisode de la grande
explication vous aura intéressé bien sûr
c'est qu'une porte d'entrée n'hésitez
pas à apporter vos compléments en
commentaire merci à lid de
l'escarmontier elle m'a raconté plein de
choses hyper intéressantes et j'ai
malheureusement pas pu tout mettre dans
cette vidéo elle m'a aussi raconté en
fait que la fonte des glaces c'était pas
la seule chose qui faisait monter l'eau
aujourd'hui il une autre contribution
qui vient pas en fait de la glace à à
cette hausse du niveau marin c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'expansion thermique
c'est le fait que quand on réchauffe les
océans comme quand on réchauffe en fait
de de l'eau cette eau va s'expenser et
donc va prendre un volume plus important
ce niveau marin il augmente d'environ 4
mm par an il y a 1/ers qui correspond en
fait à une contribution des glaciers 1/3
des calottes et 1/ers de l'expansion
thermique mais ces contributions elles
vont changer l'expansion thermique va
devenir plus faible parce qu'en fait
c'est quelque chose qui qui peut pas
évoluer sans faim euh par par contre les
contributions par exemple des des
calottes Groenland et Antarctique va
vraiment augmenter par il va prendre le
dessus maintenant sur celle des glaciers
en 2013 la revue nationale géographique
avait fait une simulation de la fondte
totale des glaces et je vous mets le
lien sous la vidéo YouTube merci à
toutes les équipes de brut qui ont
permis de faire cette vidéo et toutes
les autres que vous pouvez retrouver sur
notre chaîne YouTube et pour un nouvel
épisode de la grande explication on se
retrouve dimanche prochain